en este vídeo vamos a tratar de
averiguar cuánto es 0.6 o seis décimas
dividido entre dos y te daré una pequeña
pista tenemos seis décimas representadas
en la recta numérica por lo tanto una
manera de pensar en esto es que si
quiero ir de cero a seis décimas en dos
saltos que tan grande tendría que ser
cada uno de esos saltos pausa este vídeo
e intentar resolverlo por tu cuenta
antes de trabajar juntos muy bien como
he mencionado una forma de pensar en
esto es cómo puedo pasar de 0 a 6
décimas en dos saltos y debería decir
dos saltos iguales bueno si lo vemos así
podría ser un salto aquí y luego otro
salto aquí de modo que hice un salto y
luego dos saltos entonces una forma de
pensar es que hemos dividido seis
décimas en dos saltos y qué tan grande
es cada uno de esos saltos bueno cada
uno de esos saltos es igual a uno dos
tres décimas así que esto es tres
décimas o podría escribirlo así 0.3 aquí
tenemos otro
uno dos tres décimas así que esto va a
ser igual a tres décimas y lo hemos
pensado de otras maneras si tiene seis
de algo y lo divides entre dos tendrás
dos grupos de tres de ese algo entonces
si tiene seis décimas y quieres ponerlo
en dos grupos iguales bueno cada uno de
esos grupos será de tres décimas